today on the matt wall show i have
somehow become the number one lgbt
author in the world this is a twist no
one was no one expected we'll talk about
that today also the parents of the
oxford high school shooter are being
charged with manslaughter is that the
right move or does it set a dangerous
precedent for the future or could it
possibly be could both be true possibly
plus camilla harris's henpeck staffers
go to increasingly awkward yet hilarious
lengths to prove that they're happy to
work for her and the new york times says
that hotels in new york should be turned
into homeless encampments what could
possibly go wrong there a lot it turns
out finally in our daily cancellation
rashida talib makes a pitch for student
loan forgiveness but i'll explain why
she is herself personally a perfect
example of why there should not be
student loan forgiveness all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
now a quick word from policy genius you
know if you don't have life insurance
yet uh you should really you know i know
people kind of put it off getting life
insurance but it is a responsibility
it's a moral responsibility that you
have uh to the people who depend on you
your loved ones and the great thing is
that if it seems like a daunting task to
get life insurance it's not
or with policy genius all you gotta do
is head to policygenius.com and answer a
few questions about yourself in minutes
you can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius maybe before policy genius
this would have been a daunting task
it's not anymore their license experts
will help you understand your options
and apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
company so you know you can trust them
to offer unbiased help and advocate for
you
at every step until you're covered
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
or sell your info to third parties it's
straightforward what you see is what you
get since 2014 policy genius has helped
over 30 million people shop for
insurance you could be one of them head
to policygenius.com to get your free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you could save that's policygenius.com
well
i never imagined that i would be
responsible for writing the literary
sensation of 2021 least of all that i
would write it on cardboard and yet my
book johnny the walrus about a boy who
identifies as walrus and is now
available at johnnywalrus.com or on
amazon has taken the world by storm
critics are hailing it as a masterpiece
i haven't heard any critics say that
exactly but it's safe to assume that
they probably have said it
but forget about the critics just listen
to some of these emails i've received
i've gotten a lot of emails from people
who've gotten the book
or reacting to the book satisfied
customers have messaged me stunned by
the sheer depth and breadth of my trans
walrus novel one reader said wtf is this
supposed to be serious
another raved kind of expensive for a
board book and still another proclaimed
this is the weirdest thing you've done
and another tells me that the book is
quote funny but quote pretty
objectionable on a number of levels
see these are significant accolades and
now we can add another
johnny the walrus is the number one best
seller on amazon's lgbtq plus book list
yes on sunday morning
the lord's day a day after we had
re-released the book on amazon because
our first run sold out in less than 24
hours i awoke to discover that johnny
walrus had not only been categorized as
an lgbt book but had become the
best-selling title in that genre and
still is today
as it stands right now my story about a
trans walrus child is the number one
bestseller in lgbt books beating out
such lgbt hits as the seven husbands of
evelyn hugo
badass affirmations the wit and wisdom
of wild women the gay christmas romance
novel only one bed
a book called mr naughty and mr nice and
another book called holla gay
i never imagined i would beat out
holigay but i did
just to be very clear about this because
it seems i must emphasize this point
johnny the walrus is about a kid who
identifies as a walrus and whose mother
takes him to be to the doctor to have
him surgically transitioned and gets him
walrus hormone pills and then eventually
tries to drop him off at a zoo to live
with other walruses this amazon has
decided is an lgbt story
there would seem to be a certain
admission being made here i don't know
and you might even say that by writing a
trans walrus kids book and not only
topping the amazon charts but getting
the book classified as lgbt
our plan has worked perfectly you might
say that this whole thing is our
trolling masterpiece our sistine chapel
of trolling that's one interpretation
but it's not the conclusion that i
choose to draw from this situation
personally i take quite seriously my new
status as the leading lgbt voice in the
nation
i never expected to be such a prominent
member of the community
or to be a member at all frankly but i
will happily embrace this unexpected
role
i can tell you that i i solemnly swear
that i will faithfully fulfill the
obligations of my office
this is not something i take lightly
in other words to the lgbt lobby i have
to say i'm the captain now
but fear not i have big plans for us
going forward you're not you're you're
going to love it or you might not but i
will and as the leading lgbt author in
the world that's all that really matters
how i feel most of all and this is the
real takeaway here i think
this is this is the main point
my title is best-selling lgbt children's
author means that i am henceforth
personally exempt from all criticism and
it's important that you know that
especially if you're in the audience
because there's an obligation that falls
to you now and you have to know the
rules
any critiques of me or my opinions or my
behavior or my literary work will now be
officially and legally
categorized as homophobic hate speech
if you refuse to buy my book johnny the
walrus or to download my podcast or to
come to my birthday parties
or to invite me to your birthday parties
then you are guilty of marginalizing an
oppressed minority
if i'm censored on social media
or if somehow my book is still banned by
amazon somehow it will be gay erasure
now you now have a moral obligation to
affirm me
agree with me celebrate me and
especially to purchase my book which is
need i remind you a best-selling smash
lgbt sensation
now those of you who have followed my
work for some time know that i have long
sought membership in a societally
recognized victim group because i covet
the power that such membership affords
up to this point i've had to make a do
with the fact that i'm a member of the
visually impaired community
it's not great as victim victimization
goes but it's not nothing
yet even so i've discovered that in the
victimhood arcade not many tokens can be
won with mere physical impairments
if you want to be rich in oppression
truly wealthy you have to find your way
into the lgbt fold
and now here i am
i can feel the power coursing through my
veins
i am unstoppable
this must be what spider-man felt like
when he woke up the next morning after
getting bit by the spider
this is a fair warning then to all of my
critics i am ineligible for further
insults or denunciations
before you say anything to me or about
me just remind yourself that you are
referring to the top lgbt writer in the
world
your criticism is violence
your failure to compliment me would also
be violence
these are the rules
i didn't make them
but by god i will enforce them
so by my book you bigots
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we all look for shortcuts in life and
one of the shortcuts a lot of people use
is that you have multiple accounts
online you just use the same password
for all of them i don't use that
strategy my strategy is i have different
passwords and i always forget them so i
have to do the recover password every
time i log into anything every day
both strategies not that great
especially with um all the cyber attacks
that you could experience credential
stuffing is one of the credential
stuffing is when cyber criminals get
your username and password off the dark
web and they try to gain access to your
accounts and steal your private
information if you have the same
password on multiple accounts and they
get they get one of them now they've got
all your accounts and that's the problem
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could steal what's yours sometimes even
harm your finances your credit your
reputation anything good thing there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats and if they
detect that your information has
potentially been compromised
they'll send you an alert and they'll
get it taken care of nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
uh okay all right everyone else is
starting their shows with uh real news
and that's what i start with but you
know that's what you get on the matt
wells show that's what sets us apart for
better or worse perhaps worse
here's um here's a real story
and a very interesting case
horrible case tragic sad you know
terrible
from a legal perspective it's also
pretty complicated the parents of the
oxford high school shooter have been
charged with
involuntary manslaughter after their son
killed four people and wounded many
others last week during class
now before we talk about this decision
let's listen to the d.a karen mcdonald
explain her logic in filing these
charges now first she talks about um uh
she talked to the press on on friday and
the timing of her
address to the press or her press
conference
also we need to we need to comment on
that we'll do that in a second but so
first she explains how they went out and
uh they bought their their 15 year old
son a handgun apparently
um
the mother posted about buying the
handgun for
her son
and then the kid was posing with the gun
on social media referring to it as his
beauty
that had just been bought he didn't have
the gun in his room apparently it was in
his parents room in an unlocked drawer
and um he was caught at school i think
this was the day before or a couple days
before searching for ammo during school
hours
and the parents were notified with an
email and then and then followed up with
a voicemail but the parents never
responded to that
okay so the kids at school during school
hours looking for ammo
and uh they tried to get a hold of the
parents to tell them about it and the
mom never even called back to
to respond instead the mother texted her
son
this message
lol i'm not mad you have to learn not to
get caught
okay so that was a couple days before
the shooting and that brings us up to
the morning of the shooting and then
we'll let uh karen mcdonald fill in the
rest
on november 30th 21 the morning of the
shooting the next day
ethan crumbly's teacher came upon a note
on ethan's desk which alarmed her to the
point that she took a picture of it on
her cell phone
the note contained the following
a drawing of a semi-automatic handgun
pointing at the words quote the thoughts
won't stop help me unquote
in another section of the note was a
drawing of a bullet with the following
words above that bullet quote blood
everywhere end quote
between the drawing of the gun and the
bullet is a drawing of a person who
appears to have been shot twice and
bleeding
below that figure is a drawing of a
laughing emoji
further down the drawing are the words
quote my life is useless end quote and
to the night right of that are the words
quote the world is dead end quote
okay so that's what he was drawing on
the morning of the shooting
and then she continues on talking about
the the parents were then summoned to
the school
as you might expect
and uh here's how that went
at the meeting james and jennifer
crumbly were shown the drawing and were
advised that they were required to get
their son into counseling within 48
hours
both james and jennifer crumbly failed
to ask their son if he had his gun with
him or where his gun was located and
failed to inspect his backpack for the
presence of the gun which he had with
him
james and jennifer crumbly resisted the
idea of then leaving the school at that
time of their son leaving the school at
that time
instead james and jennifer crumbly left
the high school without their son
okay so they decided to go home as she
explains
after they were just i mean i'm
it's hard to wrap your head around that
one you're called to the school
your kid has written stuff like that on
a piece of paper
and uh they say you need to bring your
son home and the parents say well we
don't want to take off work
so they leave and the kid goes back to
class and then
soon after he's shooting up the school
let's uh keep watching
when the news of the active shooter at
oxford high school had been made public
jennifer crumbly texted to her son at 11
22 i'm sorry at 1 22 pm
quote
ethan
don't do it
end quote
at 1 37 pm james crumbly called 911
reporting that a gun was missing from
his house and he believed his son may be
the shooter
further investigation revealed that the
six hour nine millimeter handgun
purchased by james crumbly
was stored unlocked in a drawer in james
and jennifer's bedroom
the gun recovered from the shooter at
the school after the shooting was the
same gun that was purchased by his
father
james crumbly on november 26 2021
in the presence of his son
based upon the foregoing the oakland
county prosecutor's office requested
and received
authorized
we charged four counts of involuntary
manslaughter as to james crumbly and
four counts of involuntary manslaughter
as to jennifer crumbly
okay so that that's
that's the story behind why the charges
were filed which is
i think unprecedented i'm not aware of
any other case where the parents were
charged in a school shooting
like this and that's why i was very
apprehensive at first when i heard that
they were filing charges against the
parents
um
apprehensive about the the precedent of
holding parents legally liable for the
actions of their kids
and i know to some people especially
non-parents you might think well why
shouldn't you you know this should
happen more often if your kid goes out
and does something terrible
something
the worst possible thing like shooting
up a school then clearly you've failed
miserably as a parent you've done
something terrible uh yourself and and
so you should be held accountable for
that
um
and
oftentimes that's probably the case
if you've got a 15 or 16 year old kid
doing something like that it's it stands
to reason
it's a very good chance that the parents
have failed miserably or
or worse than that
but that's not always the case
i mean one of one of the realities of
parenting one of the really scary things
about parenting um
is
is that
you
your your control over your child
only goes so far
and at the end of the day they are
agents operating in the world with free
will and especially once
you know they leave your home and they
become adults and they go out into the
world
you know you can't
you can't stop them from making horrible
decisions
you know all you're able to do as a
parent is influence your child
and if you're doing it the right way and
you're and you're you are the correct
sort of influence
then yeah i mean there's
there should there shouldn't be a
situation where they're doing something
really horrible like this especially
when they're still kids
but they're you know mental illnesses
that you have to account for
and also again as they as they get older
and they they go out of the house and
they become adults especially um i mean
you know this is something people even
do if there's someone in their in their
20s who commits a horrible crime and
then the immediate assumption is oh they
must have been raised wrong
maybe
it seems like there's a pretty good
chance of that but not necessarily
because all kinds of things even if you
do everything perfectly as a parent all
kinds of things can still go wrong that
you can't control
and one of those things is simply that
this is another human being who makes
their own choices
make one bad choice leads to another
leads to another
and before you know it your kid has
fallen down this dark hole
and uh
it could be very hard to retrieve them
from it
all so that that's that's one reason why
you might be you might worry about the
precedent of charging parents in a
situation like this also
you worry about uh an activist d.a
crusading against gun rights is she
trying to put the second amendment on
trial like bingo up in kenosha
now i think there's still room for
concern on both counts especially the
second count about putting you know
about an activist d.a
especially because the d.a here
announced charges against these parents
before they had even been brought into
custody
which is another unprecedented thing
that's not the way this usually works
you go and arrest them and charge them
and then you go to the media and tell
them
what you did
but they're still walking around out
there free and you're announcing charges
and apparently they went into hiding and
it took about a day to find them they
found them in some industrial park
somewhere in michigan
which is one of the things that happens
as a da when you announce the charges
before you before you arrest the people
so that that would give the appearance
that she's in this for publicity
even so so those are the concerns and
everything
even so based on this information um
the information that she lays out we can
say that the parents at a minimum
acted with extraordinary recklessness at
a minimum
and uh
we could probably say something even
even
worse than that
and they obviously also knew that their
child was disturbed
i mean if there's a shooting at your
kid's school god forbid
and your first thought is that my kid is
the one shooting if that if your first
fear when you hear about the shooting is
that your kid is the shooter and not a
victim of a shooter
then that obviously shows that you know
your child is deeply disturbed
of course you know that
of course you know that
as a parent you're not going to know
everything about your child especially
if they go to public school and they
spend so much time out
out of sight out of you
there's gonna be a lot you don't know
about your kid
but if he's the kind of kid capable of
doing something like this
you are at a minimum going to know that
he's disturbed and he's got serious
problems
and yet you go out and buy him a handgun
leave it in an unlocked drawer
he's taking pictures on social media
with it
searching for ammo during school hours
and you laugh about it
and we know that they knew he was
disturbed because first of all they were
told about the the drawing and the
pictures and everything he wrote
but when they heard about the shooting
she texts don't do it she knew it was
him
uh yeah this goes this goes beyond
parental recklessness this is
this goes to involuntary manslaughter so
i think these are the right charges in
this case
i hope it doesn't set a precedent an
undue precedent
um
and i hope the d.a doesn't turn this it
doesn't try to turn this into a
prosecuting the second amendment type of
thing i don't know we'll find out but
you have to hold the parents
responsible in a case like this all
right moving on there have been um
reports for months now that everybody
hates camille harris at the white house
and they want to get rid of her but
they're basically stuck with her because
you can't bring her on to the job purely
because of her race and gender and then
fire her you can't do that it doesn't
work that way so there have been all
kinds of extremely forced sounding
statements from the white house talking
about how them how much they love camila
and how much respect they have for her
while the sources are
talking behind the scenes off the record
and saying she's terrible and they don't
like her
uh the public face they're putting
forward jen pasaki has come out and
they've all said oh no she's great we
love her
kind of similar to the statement you get
from nfl owners voicing their faith in
the head coach who's owen 15
two days before they fire him except
again in this case they can't do that
they can't fire her
uh so with camelo there's also been a
mass exodus of staffers leaving
resigning and there's been reports like
this from business insider and this just
came out today it says a former camel
hair staffer says aids have to endure
quote a constant amount of
soul-destroying criticism
the article goes on and says a major
issue that several staffers raised with
harris's refusal to analyze briefing
materials set forth by employees
was harris's refusal to analyze briefing
materials set by set forth by employees
which reportedly resulted in her
scolding them if she appeared to be
unprepared
quote it's clear that you're not working
with somebody who's willing to do the
prep and the work one former staffer
told the newspaper with camilla you have
to put up with a constant amount of
soul-destroying criticism and also her
own lack of confidence so you're
constantly sort of propping up a bully
and it's not really clear why
former harris aide uh
gil jill duran left her office in 2013
after five months in uh
in the role when she was california's
attorney general he told the post that
the turnover in the vice president's
office points back to her he told the
newspaper quote one of the things we've
said in our little text groups among
each other is what is the common
denominator through all this and it's
her
who are the next talented people you're
going to bring in and burn through and
then have them pretend they're retiring
for positive reasons and harris's office
has responded to this by the way and
they've said that of course this is
sexism and racism that's where all this
is coming from now this is a little
tough for me when i read stories like
this because i can completely believe
that she's a tyrant i'm sure she is
but also we have to keep in mind that
her staffers are all a bunch of whiny
millennial lick spittles
so i'm sure if you tapped them on the
shoulder and said hey your shoes untied
they would say this is soul destroying
criticism
but even so camilla is terrible and um
yet the four statements
of support coming out
are really pathetic but none of them
compare to this here's a tweet from
david gins
who's a staffer for camille he put out
this statement today or a tweet this is
last night
he says hi my name is david ginns i work
for vice president harris on behalf of
the american people as deputy director
for operations and absolutely love my
job just thought some of you should know
and there's a photo now look at this
photo let's put this photo up
my god
a picture says a thousand words and so
does this one except it's just the word
pathetic one thousand times in a row
look at the expression on his face
staring straight ahead
trying to muster a smile but there's
like this look of fear in his eyes
probably because camille is just out of
frame pointing a gun at his head
and then and then look at the photo of
camila and her husband on the wall
this is the weirdest thing i've ever
seen who put first of all who puts a
photo there at all
i'm no interior decorator my wife will
tell you that but you don't
just put a random
photograph that big
crammed up against the door
right above like the
looks like the thermostat or something
there
and why that and why that photo
it looks almost photoshopped into the
into the picture
and who has a photo of their boss and
their boss's spouse on the wall
does camilla require this of all her
underlings maybe
and i also want to point your attention
just one other thing keep this picture
up here because there's one other thing
that i've been
i've been pondering
so you also notice i want to point your
attention to that that circular hole in
the desk
right where david gins is sitting you
see
i don't want to know what that hole's
there for
this is camilla harris we're talking
about
the imagination runs wild
but uh
that's that's the best they could do
they needed to get a staffer on the
record posing for a photo looking
looking happy in his job
and the best they could get is the
deputy director
of operations sitting
at a desk with a suspicious hole
barely cracking a smile okay
this is from the daily wire says new
details emerged on sunday about why cnn
decided to fire star host chris cuomo on
saturday evening as the net network
conducted an investigation into cuomo's
role in helping his brother then new
york democrat governor andrew cuomo
navigate a sexual misconduct scandal
deborah s katz a left-wing attorney said
in a statement on sunday that she is
representing a client who claims that
chris cuomo engaged in serious sexual
misconduct against her at the network
katz said she notified cnn of the
allegations on wednesday that the
allegations are ultimately what led to
chris cuomo being fired from cnn
um
and uh so that's why they finally
announced that it was official at first
they suspended him and it was
kind of we were expecting maybe they'd
bring him back on like they did with
jeffrey toobin
but now they're getting rid of him
because of sexual misconduct at the
workplace of course
jeffrey toobin also had workplace sexual
misconduct when he masturbated in front
of his co-workers on zoom call but he's
got that exception i'm not sure why um
increasingly i've i've come to believe
that jeffrey toobin must have
compromising photos or something of
someone high up in the cnn food chain
there's got to be some explanation for
how he's still there
but andrew cuomo was gone uh brother
chris coleman and andrew cuomo
it is the fall of the cuomo house
and i think with this story
this story is kind of a
is is good because
it provides us an example of the
distinction
between canceling and accountability
the defenders of cancel culture
will will say that well no we're not
canceling people we're just holding them
accountable
but this is what accountability
looks like okay this is what
someone loses their job and they deserve
to lose it and they're being held
accountable for what they've done that's
what this looks like
because for one thing
okay he's being punished for things that
he's done currently and recently
okay helping his brother behind the
scenes
this this workplace sexual misconduct
sounds like it was recent so this is not
digging up things from a decade ago or
20 years ago
looking for a reason to get rid of him
these are things that he has done
is doing currently
and this is also focused on actions not
words or opinions
okay that's another hallmark of cancel
culture
very often you're getting canceled for
things that you've said or opinions
you've expressed
and also again very often these are
someone wants to cancel you the powers
that be want to cancel you so they go
looking they go digging for something
and they find something from 10 years
ago that nobody cared about at the time
didn't offend anybody and they bring it
up to light and they conjure up
outrage over it
that's not the case here
and the main thing of course is that
that tells us this is not a canceling is
that he's he's been given a thousand
chances
with cancel culture there's no
forgiveness of course there's no grace
there are no chances
because it's
the institutions of power deciding they
want to get rid of you
and they'll take the first excuse they
can find
here's an entirely different situation
where the institutions of power wanted
to keep chris cuomo in place
and they were willing to overlook
many different forms of misconduct and
many different ethical violations until
it just it was one thing after another
and they had no choice anymore and they
had to fire
all right uh what else do we got here
okay so you know i i remember when my
son was about six and we were we were
driving along and we stopped at an
intersection and there was a homeless
guy there and my son said to me
he asked me he said daddy why do we let
people be homeless that's what he asked
and uh
and and i said well what do you mean let
and he said well why don't we all in the
world just give give give the homeless
people money and give them a house there
are a lot of houses
and i said to him stopping such a damn
lib okay
i didn't really say that what i try to
do is instead is explain in a simple way
as possible that very often people find
themselves in these kinds of situ
unfortunate situations not because the
world necessarily forced them into it
but sometimes because of things going on
inside them
and i said that sadly for a lot of
homeless people
they have a problem that can't be
totally solved simply by giving them
money or giving them a home but we still
do give them the money we give money to
the homeless because that's the most we
can do as strangers passing by
and it's good to help people to the
extent that you can
anyway my son had a very simplistic way
of looking at the problem because he's a
child and that's fine
it's not so fine for adults though to
continue to
look at the problem with the same level
of naivete which brings us to this the
new york times it says
here's their headline as many new york
city hotels sat empty during the
pandemic and homelessness continued to
rise it was a once in a generation
chance to convert struggling hotels into
affordable housing
but none were converted so what happened
the article goes on to talk about how
all of these empty hotels were just
sitting there in new york city and you
know why why don't we put the homeless
in there
simple as that
and it points out that other cities and
other states have done exactly that
which is true
this is something that that various
different localities have tried they
tried it in tulsa and tulsaworld.com uh
just so happened to have a report on on
the progress of this program in tulsa
reading part way through here
starts with a nurse practitioner who
worked at the homeless hotel in tulsa
and it says nurse practitioner amber voe
figured she'd be consulted when it came
time to decide who would get permanent
housing and who wouldn't as the person
in charge of the hotel's health clinic
she'd gotten to know many of the clients
and believe she could contribute to the
conversation
much to her surprise and disappointment
those discussions never happened
i was the medical provider she said at
the very least i should have been
involved in some of these conversations
i didn't even know it was happening
until the people had already been told
they were being put out and they would
come into my clinic having emotional
mental breakdowns because of how scared
they were and begging me to help
vote said about 10 to 20 clients a week
were being sent back into the streets in
the last month the hotel was operating
and most were no better prepared for
life outside the hotel than they had
been when they entered
there was no incentive she continued she
says there were no there was no
incentive for them to kind of practice
skills that would make them more
successful once they were on their own
maybe in an apartment like taking care
of property showing up for appointments
just communicating with their
caseworkers
it's common knowledge that prostitution
and drug use were part of everyday life
at the hotel vo said and nothing was
done about it
she said quote these people were not
given the support they needed to be
successful anywhere addiction ran
rampant through through there we had a
lot of people confide in us that they
had been clean until they got to the
hotel but because the drug situation was
so bad there they relapsed
uh then it goes on to
many more
gritty details about how this hotel
operated
and it actually made the situation worse
for a lot of the people who checked into
the homeless hotel we got a picture here
of what these hotel rooms looked like
after the homeless had left them
and there's just
garbage shrewing all over the place
now in fairness my hotel rooms don't
look much better than that once i check
out but they they do look a little bit
better
so um
and but at least we could say there were
no from what i understand from this
article there were no meth labs in the
building
and which is better than the situation
in san francisco
where they did the same kind of thing at
a motel in san francisco and the
homeless started converting the rooms
into meth labs
now is this surprising
no
why because people who are chronically
homeless
i mean chronically not like someone who
falls on hard times and they temporarily
find themselves between housing
situations or that sort of thing
i mean chronically homeless
um they are that way in the vast
majority of cases
because they're either drug addicts or
they're severely mentally ill or both
um
your your problem it's just it's gonna
be very rare to have someone who is not
addicted to drugs and is mentally
competent
and yet is
living on the sidewalk
in you know sleeping on a cardboard box
for weeks and months on end
because a mentally competent person
who's not addicted to drugs
you know it's not it's not difficult to
find some kind of housing
might it's not gonna be great housing
but you could find something
you know you get some kind of job might
not be a great job that pays the that
pays very well but you find you should
be able to find some kind of job at fast
food or something and you can afford
some sort of housing situation
so if there are people just living on
the street
for months and months and years on end
that tells you that there is
something else going on here internally
now does this mean that it's not sad or
that we shouldn't try to help people in
the situation no of course not it just
means that the problem isn't that they
don't have homes
that's not the fundamental problem the
problem is deeper than that
the fact again is that any non-drug
addicted non-mentally ill person will be
able to find some kind of housing
so if they're not then there's something
else going on and so if if you just open
up a hotel and you
throw them in there
it's going to fall apart and go to hell
because now you have a whole lot of
mentally ill drug addicts under one roof
so you've got you got to get to the
underlying problems
but
of course in our society and with the
left we're always trying to we're always
engaging with these problems on the
surface
you can never go below the surface
we're always we're dealing with
circumstances
rather than people
and we want to pretend that um
anyone who's in a bad circumstance well
it's the circumstance is what has caused
it
we don't want to go deeper than that and
look at what's going on internally the
choices that they've made because then
we get into what what would be called
victim blaming or whatever else
all right uh what else do we got here
the surgeon general has said that this
is good news we can see our families on
the holidays under certain conditions uh
he's made this announcement let's uh
let's play that
but if you do as many families did you
get vaccinated and boosted you use
testing judiciously before you gather
you gather in well-ventilated spaces and
use masks whenever you can in public
indoor spaces your risk can be quite low
and your holidays can be quite
fulfilling that's what so many families
experience this past thanksgiving
so you wear masks with your family
get get uh jabbed and boosted make sure
everyone's jabbed and boosted
wear masks
you know socially distanced from one
another
and you can have a quite fulfilling
holiday i don't know you know
when i think about
what makes for a fulfilling holiday
experience with family
i think one of the one of the essential
aspects of that uh of that experience
what makes it fulfilling is that you can
like see each other and see each other's
faces
you really can't have any kind of
fulfilling social
interaction
when you're both covering your faces
but
i guess we have to give thanks to the
surgeon general at least for giving us
permission to celebrate christmas so we
we can do that but um
celebrate christmas as long as you're
treating your family preemptively like
they're all diseased
and it'll be fine
all right finally here's a another
sort of emperor has no clothes
situation or maybe the emperor's wearing
women's clothes i guess
a tran this is from the daily mails is a
trans swimmer and senior at the
university of pennsylvania who
previously spent three years competing
as a man
is now crushing records in women's
events sparking outrage
amid controversy surrounding transgender
athletes
you can see the picture there
there's there's the man formerly named
will now goes by leah thomas 22 has
competed a number of events recently
including a tri-meet with cornell and
princeton universities on november 20th
where the senior blasted u-pen records
in the 200-meter and 500-meter freestyle
posting times that beat almost every
other female swimmer across america
uh with a time of
143.47 in the 200 meter freestyle thomas
would have been in line to secure silver
medal at the ncaa women's championships
while while her
i'm reading from the article and this is
the pro i'm just reading verbatim in the
article
while her quote unquote 43506 and the
500 meter freestyle would have been good
enough to win bronze
um this is the latest controversy the
ongoing argument over whether trans
people should be allowed to compete in
sports alongside athletes of the
opposite gender then they were assigned
at birth oh there we go let's let's okay
can we stop there on that picture for a
second
yeah
that's a woman
folks that's that's we're supposed to
believe that's a woman
why is it a woman while he grew his hair
out
that's what makes him a woman a woman
this is probably one of the more
egregious all every case of a male
competing against women in female sports
is egregious and and ridiculous and
outrageous and wrong
uh this one more than most
because this guy
as i said in the article
he competed against men for three years
so he'd been a man his entire life
competing there he's there
in his former life
before going through the radical
transformation of growing out his hair
uh there he was
and uh
for three years
and then in his last year says you know
what i'm a woman i'm gonna go over here
and starts dominating gold silver bronze
record times
and and to show you how absurd these
kinds of situations are
it's not so much comparing the man's
time to the women that he's beating
what you really have to do and i don't
have it in front of me but i'll be
interested to do this
you take that man's time and compare it
to the other men
and what i can guarantee you is i mean
this guy he may have held his own
against uh against the men
but i guarantee he wasn't winning gold
and silver medals all over the place
okay he was he of course was not
dominating at all
certainly not not to the level that he's
dominating now
so what you usually have are uh in these
situations you have male athletes
who at best are middling athletes
the example we've talked about before in
connecticut where you've got these uh
these two guys raced against the girls
in high school track the famous case now
going through the courts
but those were those were men who barely
qualify for state competitions against
the men i mean they couldn't even get on
the track they go over against the girls
and they're you know at least in the top
three in every race
that's what that's what it always is
it's always
middling mediocre male athletes going
over to girls and dominating
which tells you of course
that that what do you know there is a
there is a
dramatic biological difference between
the sexes
but also it it continues to be very
interesting
that it's always the men in the middle
of the pack or the bottom of the pack
who discover that they're women
it's never a man at the top of the pack
has there been one single case of a man
who was dominating against the males he
was already
top three all the time and then he
discovered he was a woman and went over
and raced against the girls
i don't think it's ever happened
so you might you might conclude you
might start to suspect
perhaps
that there are some mediocre male
athletes who are um
who who
are encouraged perhaps to discover a
female identity because that's the only
way
that they can consistently win
and even if it's not even even if that's
not the case i mean even if this guy i
can't get inside his head i don't know
what his true motivations are i'm very
suspicious of what they might be but i
don't know
regardless of whatever his motivations
are it's it's still wrong
and everybody knows it
i mean you see this guy like nobody
could put up that picture again of of
him with the other girl
you see this pic no one thinks that this
is no one is looking at this they say oh
yeah those are those are those are both
women
exactly equal you know he's a woman in
the exact same way that she is
it makes total sense it's totally fair
to put them on the same team together
nobody thinks that
nobody
even far on the left they know they
don't actually believe this
it's not that they've convinced
themselves that this makes sense or it's
right or it's logical or it makes any
scientific or moral sense or that it's
justified
for them it's all politics it's all
ideology
and they simply don't care they don't
care about the
illogic of it they don't care about the
moral and ethical implications they
don't care about that
but everybody knows
i think i believe
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
finally we can talk about american
financing look if you if you've if you
own a home and you haven't refinanced
what are you waiting for mortgage rates
are at historic lows again which means
you could easily drop your rate and your
monthly payment all you got to do is
call american financing america's home
for home loans take advantage of a free
mortgage review that's right the the
review is free meaning there's no
pressure there's no obligation there's
no upfront fees just a simple
conversation with a salary based
mortgage consultant somebody who is
going to listen to and guide you so
you're getting a custom loan that
achieves your goals from lower rates to
shorter terms even the ability to access
cash from your equity
they're ready to find you the best deal
possible
does it sound too good to be true maybe
it does but it is true you could save up
to a thousand dollars a month you may
even skip two mortgage payments creating
greater upfront savings as well and you
could pre-qualify for free by calling
866 569
eleven that's eight six six five six
nine forty seven eleven uh one more time
eight six six five six nine forty seven
eleven or visit americanfinancing.net
jessica jones says having to deal with
periods and period products is awkward
enough when there are only other girls
around my discomfort would skyrocket if
there were boys a lot in the restroom
with me especially back when i was a
young teenager
um yeah jessica but as we just covered
you don't you don't matter unfortunately
um according to the left you don't
matter
you should matter but but you don't
says the left
joy barkus says
i love how the least festive daily wire
host has the most festive studio uh yeah
we do we are finally decorated for
christmas here at uh the matt walsh
studio and i don't know if you can see
and fully appreciate of course but our
our alien is uh is in the christmas
spirit he's got the
santa claus beard on and the santa claus
hat
um
daniel b says matt love seeing you love
to see you repping your own swag i was
waiting for it and you delivered it
maybe so if i may be so bold i think
there needs to be some merch allowed
uh to us
the uh some matt wall skinny jeans and
polka dotted shirts just a thought love
the show
well we will always be adding a new swag
to the swag shack which you can go to
dailywire.comshop
and um yeah i have been i've been
angling for we need at least a polka dot
shirt
i don't know why you would say we need
skinny jeans i don't wear skinny jeans
as we cover many times oh and you're
banned from the show for saying that by
the way almost forgot
um sarah says we need a makeup tutorial
from sean with matt as the test subject
now listen sarah i may be the most
prominent lgbt author in the country but
i have my limits could i draw the wine
somewhere okay
deep wild violet says hospice nurse here
i've heard lots of people say at the end
of their life either that they are happy
to have their family around them or that
they regret not spending more time with
family on vacations with people they
love etc i have never heard a patient
say they wished they'd have worked more
or made more money regardless of
economic class
yeah and that's kind of a unique insight
that and perspective that you have
tragic insight and perspective
but having never
you know i've never worked in hospice
myself i've only been around a few
people at the end of their lives but um
this would seem apparent
we could see that
within ourselves too
like you can look forward
to your own death whenever it comes
might be tomorrow it might be in 50
years whatever
and you already know what sorts of
things you're going to regret what sorts
of things you wish you had done more
often
[Music]
another great example is um
you know we all spend 15 hours a day on
our phones and staring at screens
but i'm pretty sure and you correct me
if i'm wrong
you've also probably not had any anybody
uh in their in their last breaths at
hospice
say that they wish they'd spent more
time staring at screens
so we know that i mean while we're
sitting there for 15 hours looking on
the phone you just know that you're
gonna that this is a total waste of time
you're going to regret it
but we can't help ourselves
um
girder says hey matt i think you'll love
that
the tidbit that not only is it fairly
common and normal for a six-year-old to
be a fortnight expert it's fairly common
gamer knowledge that about 90 of
fortnite experts are under the age of
10.
yeah i don't i can't remember what that
was referring to but there was yeah some
someone who who said that their
six-year-old son was a fortnight expert
um
there's no reason for that
okay now i i understand by most people's
you know judgment i'm i'm kind of
extreme on this
that i don't plan on my kids playing
video games at all but i but i but i do
understand that as the kids get a little
bit older and they become teenagers it
might be more difficult to keep them
away from that stuff
and
you know maybe you start introducing
some but but at the age of
six the age of six it's it's very very
easy to determine what kind of
entertainment
your kids are gonna have access to
and so that's a choice you have to make
if your kid at six years old or five
years old is addicted to video games
like i know so many are you've chose you
have made that lifestyle choice for your
kid
which doesn't make any sense to me at
all on thursday biden announced his
winter coveted plan and it's apparent
that his administration is only going to
double down on their authoritarian
policies not only did biden announce
that he's extending the federal mass
mandates for public transportation but
jen pasake admitted that the
administration is actually considering
requiring americans to be fully
vaccinated in order to fly domestically
you heard that correctly if you want to
visit your family for the holidays you
may need to drive across the country
rather than fly or you need to comply
the buy administration is working
overtime to force you to do the latter
that's why our lawsuit against biden's
vaccine mandate for private employers is
so vital we need to stop this madness
before it grows if we prevail in federal
court it will weaken the bond
administration's ability to implement
these authoritarian measures but we need
your help if you haven't signed our
petition denouncing binds and biden's
authoritarian vaccine mandate i need you
to stop what you're doing right now
and or stop after the next segment and
then you can do it but either way
go to dailywire.com do not comply and
add your name to the petition we need to
send an overwhelming message to this
administration that the american people
will not comply
we have a goal of reaching one million
signatures which would provide a major
boost to our legal challenge we're more
than halfway to our goal but we need
your help to cross the finish line so
please sign the petition at
dailywire.com
do not comply
and
um
my best-selling children's book you know
i've accomplished many things in my
lifetime but just last week i made one
of my ultimate dreams come true uh my
best-selling children's book that as you
know sold out in less than 24 hours
and was also as we talked about to start
the show crowned the best-selling lgbtq
plus book on amazon
uh this is a sensation everyone's buying
it everyone's talking about it across
the entire world and if you want to get
your copy go to johnnythewallrisk.com
it's back on amazon now but uh the
easiest way to get the book is go to
johnnythewallers.com and reserve your
copy today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we canceled probably not for the
first time mid-tier squad member rashida
talib we last saw rashida in an
interview on axios explaining why all
federal prison inmates including sex
traffickers and child rapists should be
immediately released from prison
the idea she was hawking on the house
floor this week isn't or last week
rather isn't quite as bad as that but
it's almost as bad
it's a bit more mainstream anyway and
that is student loan forgiveness
but the interesting thing about rashida
rashida's pitch for student loan
forgiveness is that she is herself a
perfect example of why we should not
forgive student loans
listen for yourself
i worked full time
monday through friday and took weekend
classes to get my law degree and still
close to hundred thousand dollars in
debt
and i still owe about seventy thousand
dollars
and most of it was interest
most of it was our own government making
money and profit off of me
and guess what i didn't go to the
for-profit entities i went to legal aid
i worked at the non-profit organization
fighting for you know the right to
breathe clean air to fight for the
worker that was getting their wage uh
you know taken and stolen from their
employer i went and worked on immigrant
rights and so much more
and all of that to say
we have to stop treating as if folks
that are paying for education as if they
bought some bougie car or some big you
know something beyond no
they were seeking an education
okay so rashida talib wants debt
forgiveness and uh she complains that
she still has 70 grand left on her loan
which was originally 200 000
for a law degree she says
a degree that she's chosen not to use
she admits that she immediately took
that degree that cost her well into six
figures to attain and went off to be an
activist at a nonprofit
now she's a politician
fortunately for her she makes 175 000 a
year in her current job
which raises the question why should the
taxpayer assume her debt when she earns
an income more than double the national
average
the fact that elected representatives
earn more than double the national
average is a separate issue entirely i
mean i think that they should get paid
they should get paid the national
average income that's what i think
um
for now though the point is simply that
she she chose the most expensive
education path possible now she rakes in
a sizable salary and yet still insists
that the taxpayer fulfill her financial
obligations for her
the appropriate response to that arg to
that argument is no
pay your debts you damned deadbeat
now i'm glad that rashida talib has
wanted to make herself the face of this
issue because she is the face of it as
an affluent upper-class brat with a
graduate degree she does indeed
represent a large portion of the people
clamoring for debt forgiveness in fact
people with graduate degrees account for
half of all student loan debt
half
that's because the average amount of
student debt for bachelor degrees is
only about 30 000
not insignificant but manageable the way
that we get to into trillions of dollars
collectively
in terms of debt is through all of these
people getting master's degrees where
the average debt is 70 000 and law
degrees and medical degrees where the
average debt is 150 and 200 000
respectively
so when you hear about debt forgiveness
just know that half of that money money
that will come from the taxpayer from
you will be going to upper class
affluent highly educated doctors and
lawyers and so on
student debt forgiveness is upper class
welfare that's what it is
of course i realize that plenty of
people with graduate degrees are not
doctors or lawyers
some of them are not getting paid well
at all the you know the two years
master's degree programs are largely
useless
an enormous scam
and many people today are walking around
with graduate degrees that serve no
purpose whatsoever and there's been no
return on investment
contrary to leap's claim they are indeed
like
you know basically getting a bougie car
those graduate degrees they're
superfluous extravagant useless
showy at least you can drive cars you
can't do anything with mostly graduate
programs but even so who should be on
the hook to pay for your superfluous and
useless graduate degree you or your
neighbor
really if we wanted to talk about debt
forgiveness for the middle class for
average working class americans we'd be
forgiving mortgages or credit card debt
or car payments
that's the kind of debt that most people
deal with most of us don't have a 200
000 slip of paper sitting in a frame and
hanging on a wall in our office
maybe the student debt forgiveness
proponents though would say sure yeah
let's forgive all that debt too
but that only that only proves that
they're a bunch of mental children
they have no understanding of or
appreciation for the financial realities
of life they think a magic wand can be
waived to solve all these problems even
as the government's magic wand that it
waved over the last two years has led to
skyrocketing inflation and an economic
situation that's even worse than the one
that these measures were supposed to
solve in the first place
when it comes down to it this this is
again
a question of
who should be responsible for the debts
that you take on
if you enter into a contract
and agree to pay x amount for y product
or y service
who should be the one to hold up your
end of the bargain and there are only
two possible answers to that question
you
or everybody else
you might prefer the latter option
everyone else but it's not justifiable
on a logical or moral or financial basis
i'm sorry if you went to a master to get
a master's degree so you could teach the
abc's to first graders
i'm very sorry that such a terrible
decision has caused you heartache i am
but my well of sympathy dries up the
moment you turn to the government and
ask it to point its guns at me
and reach into my wallet to solve your
problems
you immediately go from being a
sympathetic yet silly figure to a thief
now all that said i do agree that our
approach to higher education is
untenable
and that's why i think we need to
evaluate that approach rather than
simply trying to get rid of the debt
while leaving the fundamentally broken
system still in place
okay so this is this this again like we
talked about with the left is just like
solve the homeless price crisis by
putting all the homeless in hotels
yet they're still mentally ill drug
addicts
so we solve our broken higher education
system by just forgiving
all the debt but the system is still
broken
the solution to the debt crisis going
forward the way to staunch the bleeding
anyway and make sure it doesn't get
worse
is to stop sending our kids into
four-year institutions by default
most of them don't need to be there and
won't gain anything of lasting value
from the experience
if there was a massive drop-off in
enrollment
and we encouraged our kids to be more
discerning about the choice to enroll in
college and we push them to explore
other options aside from four-year
institutions
then many of these problems will begin
to sort themselves out
colleges for one thing wouldn't be able
to charge lamborghini prices for degrees
if they had to compete not just with
each other
but with the whole array of other
options that the world presents
if only people would explore them before
signing up for the college path
that's the point that rashida talib
ignores or outright it rejects
she wants to keep the spigot turned on
siphoning millions of kids into the
university pipeline whether it will
benefit them or not
only she wants the government to be even
more involved in funding and
facilitating the whole disastrous system
so as usual she has it all exactly
backwards
and for that she is
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show white
nationalists march in washington dc but
only the media seem to care chris cuomo
is out at cnn and the biden
administration considers new covet
restrictions that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen